oh and welcome to the honest trailer
commentary not for mrs. Doubtfire but
Mary Poppins this is the show where we
talk about our reasoning our thinking
our jokes that didn't make the cut for
the honest trailer so go ahead and watch
that first or not I guess if you stick
around to the end you'll see some
deleted scenes cut jokes things of that
nature this week was Mary Poppins
another musical one right those are
always fun right yeah yeah so we had the
help of a Matt cetrone I'm hope I'm
pronouncing that right citron citron who
has done the last few of these and just
has knocked it out of the park yet again
crushed it crushed it
I don't know how he ropes and he did
greatest showmen definitely and then
this was like the Michael Bolton the
nice stuff yeah awesome think that was
the first time he did okay because he
wasn't recorded with Bolton so yeah so
when we drop honest trailers the album
we got a we get back a studio with Matt
oh yeah but you know all the originals
it will not be any of our parodies now
something I didn't put in managed to fit
into the script but is nonetheless true
and I'm sure people be yelling at us in
the comments we left out a lot of songs
well yeah but because there's are a lot
of singing in this movie so much there's
no jolly holiday and there's no the old
a day with no tuppence so what would
have the honest jolly holiday song been
well we he's me he's wasn't takes yeah
right yeah like he wrote Charlie holiday
and replaced it with
maybe Chim Chim Cheree if that's the one
that recurs or yeah Stepan no I think
Stephan time yeah we replace to a step
in time so many and we only have so much
time and money format to help us what
are the songs they're the best takers
yeah there's to see two songs that
literally put the children to sleep like
when they fade back in from the song
montage they are passed out there's the
two songs at the beginning that just
establish how bad the parents are each
of them has a song of like I'm a stupid
then there's a song about compound
interest it's like yeah oh it's so kids
talking about what kind of nanny they
want
oh there's a couple classified ads yeah
if I I feel like if I stop paying
attention to the song then like I don't
want to try to make yeah especially
tough it's like yeah I'll do it further
movie I don't really get the it's a
great performance and there are some
standout songs but this is kind of like
the jungle book for me where it's like
they're just messing around for this
kind of for 90 minutes in the middle of
it and there's a little plot at the
beginning a little plot the end and the
rest is just like it's not bad it's
weird
enjoy your life but yeah the story is
mr. banks growing and changing the kids
which I don't see which which happens
completely off-camera the rest is just
around with the kids yeah it is
it is a movie with like no arcs or like
on-screen marks at least like she
doesn't change because by design she's
not supposed to like why would I fall in
love with bla bla bla bla bla bla and
Bert doesn't need an arc cuz he's
magical and whatever yeah always not
magic we'd be squib I guess he'd be a
squib if we're gonna stick with Harry
Potter terms yeah it's sad if he's do we
just want him to be magical because we
don't want to admit the reality of him
just working the homeless right
he's very homeless yeah he's like he's
basically like a like a lyft driver who
sleeps in his car like he's just doing
all these gigs his best he can
curls up in the bass drum from his
one-man oh poor guy
yeah but he puts a cheery face on it
sure but yeah yeah I think you're right
like there's no real arcs you don't see
mr. banks actually change so it's like
really jarring
when they're just like your fire yeah
yeah to me it's like very condensed at
the at the very very end of the film
yeah is he's the one that needs to grow
and it's too you know let his hair down
so to speak and then he just gets his
job back and they probably went back to
being the same guy yeah after killing
after killing his boss laughter the
interesting is like Bert even calls it
out in the movie we like to the kids
he's like who's looking out for your dad
he like works his ass off and like you
two never really mind him and your mom's
a and like and so they even call
it out where it's like he's not awful
he's just yeah work now Maya
my assumption having not read the books
is that they're I never have I that
that's what's missing is either I feel
like they tweaked the SIP sympathetic
miss of Mary and mr. banks to make it
like a kids movie where they're just
going on adventures yeah it's very
lackadaisical yeah it's very I I had not
seen this as a kid so I was like this
movie just kind of in my head it was all
very logical through line and then I was
like now they just kind of meander
around like it's nice I love them
laughing with Edie wind and giggling
cool those penguins are delightful yeah
sure but you get about two hours in and
you're like oh we're still here huh yeah
dancing Julie Andrews is not in it as
much as I remembered like a lot of it is
Dick Van Dyke yeah yeah like just kind
of get worse now that I'm realizing it
like the kids are actually like pretty
sweet normal like we're sorry we just
our kite got away and we tried to chase
the kite dad are bad and then by the end
like their dads like you want to open it
savings account they're like yeah that's
right popping incepted in their minds
yeah okkk lumen sea or whatever dark
magic she has very recesses yeah
well should we watch it sure let's see
it's it's a long one but we can't cut
anything I guess we did cut some stuff
yeah but the songs just we would have
been a 12-minute long trailer yeah and
we'd still be working on yeah the songs
are not easy to write no no Joe
thankfully cracked revisit Disney's best
live-action film of the 60s with our
apologies to fans of the know mobile the
horse in the gray flannel and the
computer wore tennis shoes Applejack
it's absolutely right young Kurt Russell
Applejack Chisholm City social club
Applejack Pompeii Palace stick around
long enough to run the world they spend
like three decades making movies yeah
pause just do yourself a favor and look
up every list of Disney's films not
animated but all of their films from the
50s onward because it's not just Mary
Poppins and Herbie no and the Apple
Dumpling gang Disney I'm gonna say it's
a Disney yes there were so many things
like you know buy this monkey got is in
trouble yeah a lot of monkey movies just
in general yeah yeah what the moon the
comics things just like things that
sound like somebody would yell in the
1950s and the shoes on the other hoof
yeah so it is real a did well I guess
that was just the popcorn flicks of
their day yeah yeah came out to see him
but what the moon was the venom of the
60s wrong way sister a lot of that it's
about nuns yes exactly exactly
the briefcase that wouldn't stay closed
you know relatable 50 stuff
and I guess that's what Troy McClure
movies were parody yeah so fun facts
keep going
very puppets meet Mary Poppins magic
nanny and full-blown narcissist
practically perfect in every way never
misses an opportunity to check herself
out doesn't get close to anyone what
would happen to me if I loved all the
children I said goodbye to and creates a
pocket universal phrases but she isn't
just a sing-song Slytherin she's also
just a so-so nanny who leaves kids alone
to go on a date
drugs them before bed and gas lights
anyone who discovers her powers until
they begin to doubt their own sanity a
respectable person like me in a horse
race how dare you suggest this thing go
to sleep okay let's see him pause I mean
she does this a lot she definitely does
it to the dad where she again in steps
ideas into his head and then that's how
she gets hired that's how she gets hired
yeah and how she doesn't get fired yep
that's how she sends them to the bank
mm-hmm it's weird she's just flat out
doing magic and then she's like no you
didn't see what you just saw yeah it's
messed up it is really yeah I don't know
what her angle is I think it's so that
they can convince themselves that they
it was in their head all along well I
think I don't know it's these cruel I
don't know a lot about the English but I
have watched Downton Abbey yes and I
think it's just not proper to have a
pocket animated universe full of
penguins that want to make out with you
so she's just like what are you talking
about oh that's ridiculous
yeah and then like I don't know what the
inverse of of gas lighting is but every
way everyone treats
they're like homicidal Navy captain
neighbor like Oh him Hey Oh everyone's
just adapting to his delusional world
that he lives inside while he's about to
fire off his cannons at us let's get
ready
hold down the hatches like everyone's
just deluding everyone else they live in
this weird psychological world
games everyone's playing games like I
saw yeah yep
I don't know someone needs to talk to
that guy yeah desperate need of help
yeah yeah yeah on the hour which means
every hour is a nice leap no I'm sorry
someone really needs to talk to his Smee
yeah that guy's maybe lost I feel like
the moment a constable saw them load a
cannon ball like a cannon
yeah gonna come with me yeah yeah yeah
twisted twisted stuff alright keep
contact which going from house to house
in England how much you want to bet she
works for the Ministry of Magic too bad
she's Lee's happiness to the banks mrs.
banks who's there to show you can be a
good mom or an advocate for women's
rights is it mrs. banks problem in this
movie hmm
do tell she is a devoted suffragette
unless her husband says no which doesn't
yeah well it we little dismissed banks
belittles the suffragette movement I
feel like because it's like she's such
an airhead she thinks women can vote
that seems implication yeah go to a
protest you can't she's like an awful
like the scene where um where she's like
who's watching the kids and like you
have to and she just starts naming
people cuz she's like I have to go to my
fun thing yeah it's just like she said
not a good care
it's weird I see a lot of people say
that this movie is like a really good
parody of like toxic masculinity and
she's a great character and like not a
parody but like a really good it has
like a lot of great statements about it
and like she's a great character and
this and that and I'm kind of like I
feel like no one's a winner in this
booth no I feel like she literally and
metaphorically like hangs up her
suffragette thing
to be a stay-at-home mom yeah yeah yeah
well cuz that's the that is the if
you're reading into what the movie
saying the dad's journey mr. banks is
journey as he goes from being a banker
to someone who has time to fly his kite
with his kids and the moms thing is like
it needs a tail and she ties her to her
suffragette thing to the kite it feels
like and I'm gonna give up all that
nonsense to it's like wait wait if we
were talking it's like it reminds me of
the what is l-3 what's the one that's in
oh yeah yeah is it a parody of she's
just a poorly realized kid I can't
figure it out yeah it's like I hate how
political Disney gets these days oh my
god their lines in this movie that would
be like holy God it would make stuff it
wouldn't it makes the last gen I look
like nothing it's just like yeah we all
know men are stupid right I'm just like
holy crap like this would be like the
most attacked movie of all times but
it's it to me it's especially strange
because it's like this was made in the
60s the suffragette movement was decades
before that again although I don't know
I haven't read the book maybe it's in
the book what do I know maybe the
original text people can help us out
it's very odd yeah it's know in the
coments yeah yeah I've gone George the
only man in Hollywood history to hire a
beautiful nanny and have his marriage
get better
literally dick around for 90 minutes I
was gonna put up a grand of
working-class people may be suffering
from poverty in black lung but they're
actually good luck charms and secretly
magic so go ahead and get your dad fired
from his white collar job he'll sing it
off in no time so step in time with his
timeless musical that will make you
forget Disney rip this IP away from its
creator made of really no never touch
Poppins again then Disney made a movie
about her where Walt's the hero and
she's an impossible shrew is not a what
then wait until she died and me to deal
with her estate for a sequel yeah that's
me yeah yeah so Disney like
would not leave her alone about this IP
until she finally kind of like just gave
in yeah and and then they bit wrote
another one right with for Julie Andrews
like in the 80s I was reading and soon
they took her and she's like no yeah
interest absolutely not and then after I
think it's after she passed away they
dealt right they financed the play to
sort of like rebuild the relationship
with the estate but it's like that this
whole story is I don't I mean now it's
like Oh Disney's a mean corporation what
like now it's kind of like I mean yeah
that's obviously that's probably what
they would do but like when you look
back and just everything about Mary
Poppins is like this is the Golden Age
of Disney and blob and all this like
feel good feel good and it's like man he
just like he didn't steal it you know
like he didn't trick her into signing a
document but he definitely her rang to
this poor woman until she was finally
like okay but I'd like some some
creative control and they went okay and
then may can they literally made a movie
like being like look at this crazy lady
with daddy issues yeah can you believe
her I know it's really kind of rubbing
it in was made Julius yeah the movie
after the fact she's the most likable
guy in Hollywood is guy couldn't
possibly hate for any reason as Walt
Disney yeah guy knew how to hold a
grudge good for him
can't keep going house we love like the
recently unemployed song
[Music]
tonight
the sugarcoat for something song first
rap this was a lot more depressing yeah
where the spoonful of sugar was just
like a metaphor for like you know life
sucks yeah oh she may be means more
literally like a spoonful of something
helps yeah yes the original was like all
our material things they're just
distractions cuz life aboard the
metaphorical like you got to lie to
yourself to get through the day yeah
that that might be the the honest
meaning of it but no I think she really
means like take a spoonful or something
and then yeah I mean it's easy sugar
yeah I'm not sure who the singer is that
Matt works with but she's great
yeah she does it did good Andrews keep
going Disney women adverts they can all
commune with nature they're druids
it's like a 45-minute on that line yeah
the one is depends on the terrain do you
want to say what they're actually what
he is saying yeah
he says DuckTales twice swaying is that
for like buckets and pails I wrote duck
tales once and then I was like what if
he said it twice just so okay someone
was like did he say yes yes he did wait
a minute
yeah well because uh the idea was always
just
we sent like just parentheses like
cottony nonsense to man he like did it
but like wasn't quite in the rhythm and
so we just I don't know you spelled it
out yeah I just like spelled out
nonsense and included duck tails and it
worked this is gonna become boring
really quick because I can't find it if
I search for the word duck tails will
more than one email chain do you have
problems or tails email - how many times
have you written ducked an email Jo if I
were to just bet over-under - I'm gonna
save 47 I think if I I think if I search
for duck in my email maybe one like yeah
all right I'll help you out dan you
drive all right let's keep going I found
it oh I've seen my time - Joestar yeah
it's a boy deep
ergo ducktales cuz brockett's all Smee
group tree dil shucks off lortz of
ducktales til brew perfect cuz there you
go perfect
all right now mystery solved the dumbest
email amounts of carcinogen song yeah
there was something like that chimney
long there was like a chimney sweep
disease named after Kim be sweet
[Music]
is this the only other 14 syllable work
now there's like two others I think this
is one I figured out wrong school it's
all chemically accurate by the way yes
it's correct story
there's something about Mary joy been
doing guvnah first name Abby happy feet
the bird lady from home alone -
definitely Mary Poppins just murderer
ladies they needed jobs - written how to
mine them just are nice thank you do you
know the worst thing about living in a
noir d in England all the chimney sweeps
flash bombing on your roof rehearsing
[Laughter]
saying that of the mic and wrote around
it yeah yeah that's I was watching that
was just like oh my god like I would be
so upset if I lived in that house yeah
like that'll fit that is especially when
they're like downstairs others shaking
his hand and stuff that is the moment
that really cements it for me where I'm
like mr. Frank like poor guy poor guys
we get to the business at work - yeah
criminal mafia and the house doesn't
even like it magically cleaned up or
anything like she doesn't like spoonful
of sugar the room after they'll leave
just covered in filth and then they're
like let's go check out the view jerks
jerks
all right well let's see what we didn't
put in the little extra Dick Van Dyke in
there that we didn't even know would be
in there yeah
bonus check for my nanny Granger nanny
oh gee
goldman sachs daddy snore bucks bringing
mr. Beggs banks and banks in banks don't
tell Mom the babysitter's fled to get on
I'm on a boat
who can smiie if that song came out
imagine yeah oh boy but better things to
do then they weren't so insecure about
their manhood that disney movies would
send them into a collecting spiral yeah
yeah anyways let's keep going
adventures in babysitting I'm sure the
seek will be fun and all but can we cut
to the chase and see married team up
with Nanny McPhee and Paddington Bear is
a whimsical British superhero team and
Washington I'm glad they sorted out
who's looking after the children but
what the banks really need is a dog
sitter has been filled yeah I mean it's
not clear from those shots but the dog
just kind of comes out of nowhere when
they're outside yeah dog you back inside
yeah yeah uh there it is Mary Poppins we
did it yeah I don't know if we'll do
Mary Poppins returns Dan what do you
think you've seen it okay this is all
you get
Poppins heads the one little bonus thing
that came out of this was you were
looking for your Mary Poppins notes and
found an old Mary Poppins after credits
script yes fans will remember after
credits yeah Oh or you can see a few of
them on a he should rewrite yeah for
Mary Poppins yeah it was very much the
joke we reused
he is looking
for Harry Potter yes she's a deputy like
she she flies off and then her Death
Eater tattoo like the timeline doesn't
work but I really liked it yeah we were
trying to be like I would it be
Grindelwald that she works yeah yeah
well I still get so many good yeah
there's some good ideas yeah man that
sucker credits was a show we did on our
pay wall channel that you can't you see
except for the few episodes not deleted
but yeah some of them are on his sheet
and there's some there's some unmade
scripts that uh mhm we did a we did the
new trilogy holiday special oh that was
good the Star Wars Holiday Special
was but we wrote a spot on yeah what
would end up happening with last Jedi
and everything yeah
is that when there's the the conference
room thing right or no no one were there
sit around the conference rooms like
alright who has ideas as the force
awakens like that I think ins know yeah
there's that but it was a whole we did a
full christmas carol script yeah where
george lucas is like good ghost of Star
Wars past JJ's Star Wars president and
then I think JJ was future again I don't
remember whose future
oh no future what man it was um no it
was George was future because they
wanted to bring back yeah the favor so
had they wanted them back we this is
what see that's a sixteen right Ryan did
Ryan Johnson wasn't even attached yet I
don't think at that point we'll see
Independence Day went to is very
independent a president lost a debate to
try before you as president yeah good
stuff for more tales from paid services
past tune in next week no or nope I
guess we're not gonna do one for next
week's trailer because it's yeah okay
it'll be a super cut and then after that
what to do a post commentary for you or
you can Kent what January first will be
January first will be because anything I
say is gonna give it away what's it
what's a subtle one first five things
that popped in my head are well we
worked on it really hard yeah yeah we
had different opinions about the movie
okay we did and we are working on the
honest trailer right now we are that's
not a clue is it it is yeah oh okay
well you be the judge we'll see you soon
you know we're still gonna be on this
channel just it'll be from the past
that's how video tape works and and
we'll see you again in the new year
bye bye let's behold today's
[Music]
you